how fun is the best I don't know two
years maybe you getting some this
weekend right up you're gonna get at
least two dicks this weekend for crying
out loud Deena we only convenient for
three days well three to experience you
know what I need you to use your lady
mouth I need you to use your lady mouth
we haven't hung in five years this is
about us we are here together today is
the last day that we will ever be this
young I'll offer get pregnant I'm ready
this is hand-stitched embroidery from a
tribe in Guatemala so they're not
[ __ ] in Guatemala we got [ __ ] reduce
a bucket lesbian who can stand a brave
green pin making memories that we can
laugh about for the rest of our lives
because that's what a girl's took this
bull on ground I have to pee look the
line is short over there there's a long
line in the bathroom here just go for
ah [ __ ]
[Music]
move your ass no more boo that's a
shocker boo boo right there you know I
got some bomb-ass cush if you want to
take it here we need you hat with a
friend don't shine
you know what sticking cause of modeling
section here you can y'know infection in
your booty ho its Booga
[Music]
you